al final no pudo ser mucha tristeza en
este momento aquí en la playa de
Copacabana donde a pesar del calor y del
sol millares de personas se han reunido
para seguir el partido con la emoción a
flor de piel hacía 20 años que Brasil no
ganaba un título sería su sexto va a
tener que esperar otro cuatro años Esto
es lo que nos han dicho algunos hinchas
estoy triste Brasil merecía esta
Victoria ganar el mundial traer alegría
al pueblo brasileño este pueblo tan
feliz tan alegre que conmemoran todo
pero la vida sigue
[Aplausos]
en este momento siento tristeza y odio
pero estoy feliz estoy en la playa hace
sol hay cerveza fría cosas de carioca
sabes cómo es
al ritmo del pancariota la música de las
pamelas de Río de Janeiro en Copacabana
sigue la fiesta ya se sabe los cariocas
son alegres son un buen perdedores y por
encima de todo aman el fútbol y
al final apoyando a la mejor selección
entonces que gane el mejor